và hoàn toàn tình được gọi là tấn thần nền và sống bị càng đã bị khởi tối trong buạn vì phạm quy định về khai thác tại quyền và kể toán
với hầu quảng nghiêm trọng sẽ ra tại công tiền mà và các đình bị khó lịch quạt.
Mùi ăn tấn nằm mới mốt tùi, quế thành hóa, thường gọi tấn thần nền và sống bị càng bị khởi tối.
Lịch quán đến những sai phạm trong khai thác khoảng sản tại mọi đất sáng tự sơn, việc đung cống tình thành hóa.
Trong bởi bị càng này, mỗi anh tấn và bà bị khăn thốc bị khởi tối về hai tối.
Ví vạm quy định về khai thác tại nguyên và vi vạm quy định ở về kể toán với hộ quảng nghiêm trọng.
Cậm cộng sốc đều tra tự phạm về thăm những tình tế của lợp đã làm gió.
Mỗi anh tấn thành lợp điều hành hoặc đông hàng chục giây nghiệp được quý bán như rất tình thành hóa, tất dễ khác hai thác khoảng sản chết để bà tình hóa.
Tấn đã chỉ đạo các đối tự linh quan, tụi chức hay thác ngoài phạm vi được tất fét,
vượt tôn sốc theo quy định của dễ khác với tổn khối lực tạp bị tương.
Cơ thai bà cao không đúng với khối lực thác, giả chị mua bán khoảng sản.
Đi ngoài xùa xác, chia giấu cơ quan chức năng một tình dân thô tụi tế, tụi việc tự khoảng sản.
Gới thiệt hại rất nghiêm sọc tài sản như nước.
Cậu sức của mỏ ló là bốn trầm nghiêm trường năng.
Nhưng một tự kẻ thác lên tức bảy trầm nghiêm gì vượt quá con sức trô phép.
Bì tối chiến gì hụi vừa phép bật.
Tụi tụi bị ràng hoàn lắm mỏ tụi một trường bảy trầm.
Mà tụi khách thế thì là tụi là rắm cơ mỏ.
Tụi ra đây thì tụi mì hiểu về pháp bật và tụi bán tụi các mình nghiệp thì bán sống sống ý.
Nhưng tụi sức hình năng bà lình, chỉ để lấy ràng hoài dạm bà lì ra một chiến một đau khối.
Cậu tưởng thái thác, vượt tôn sức, vượt tôn sức, vượt tôn sức, vượt tôn sức.
Dì phép, và vi pham quyền về kỳ quán để ngoài số phát.
Một số tiền của lường tiền không khai nảo tụi.
Nhằm một lịch là vượt lợi.
Nhìn này, cứ quan trả điều ra, đăng tiệt tục, điều đá mưa rộng của anh.
Dên cuộc kể sất dưu trà tự pham về tham dúng tình để bước lâu.
Đăng tiệt tục cùng có tài điều, chúng cứ chứng mình hành vi pham tội của các địa cánh đá khởi tổ.
Đồng thời mở giúp điều tra làm gió sử lịch quan dịch chiếp đề.
Lui với hành vi sải phạm có tụi trước của nguyên anh tưởng và các cánh nhân lên quan.
Sát mình kê biên pham phà phục vụ tụi ở chiếc đề tại sạm chân nhận nước.
Cục kênh sát điều tra tội pham về tham dúng tình tế một lộ bộ công an thông báo để nhận dân
mết và tổ ra cánh vi vi pham báo lột của nguyên anh tốn.
Bà các lối tượng lên quan.
Nên tổ ra, lưu đến đề chỉ đa hiện trên mạnh.